c'est un personnage de l'agglomération
orléanaise et qu'est ce que va dire ma
femme c'est vous voir bravoure embrasser
tout le monde à la télé jean pierre
gonthier chef d'entreprise et dirigeants
du fleury loiret handball depuis plus de
dix ans ancien rugbyman sa présence à la
tête d'un club de hand féminin peut
étonner
et pourtant il croit en son projet moi
je suis fier dans cette équipe d'avoir
toutes les nationalités toutes les
couleurs et toutes les religions
quasiment et et sa vie ensemble donc ces
femmes qui ont appris à vivre ensemble
ne pouvons faire que des familles qui
sont ouvertement
consécration l'an dernier le club a
remporté la coupe de france fleury
devient donc une équipe de premier plan
pourtant développé un club féminin est
un effort de tous les
c'est d'abord les élus ou je leur en
veux beaucoup devraient quand même
penser qu'il ya autant de femmes qui
votent que d'hommes ces mêmes on répond
même pas nos courriers c'est quelque
chose qui ne le nombre et aucune
dimension de sport féminin
jean pierre gauthier se comporte dans
son club comme un chef d'entreprise tout
en restant disponible pour ses joueuses
wen la patience avec les si je pense la
rigueur et puis surtout surtout surtout
aide écoute parce que voilà on est on
est on est avant tout d'eux avant d'être
des joueuses de sportys portier de haut
niveau pardon aider des femmes donc donc
ouais on a besoin d'écouter ce n'est pas
le même sport mais les problématiques
sont les mêmes à 100 km de là bienvenue
au bourges basket club dirigé par pierre
fosset là aussi rien n'a été simple
il ya certaines personnes bienfaisante
effectivement qu'il disait bon dans cinq
cantons club il est mort ça fait quand
même plus de 25 ans maintenant donc on a
encore de l'espoir
à 62 ans pierre a passé deux tiers de sa
vie au club comme joueur puis dirigeant
sous sa présidence pour j'ai été douze
fois champion de france et a remporté
quatre titres européens malgré tout
l'exposition médiatique reste très
faible
seules quelques unes du journal l'équipe
par exemple pour être champion d'europe
pour avoir sa une de l'équipe a et ses
soeurs je veux être au moins champion
d'europe
je pense quand même quand nettement et
en étant objectif c'est parce que c'est
du sport féminin
ce serait simplement du sport masculin
je pense qu'il aurait pas de souci pour
avoir la une à l'image du projet de
nouvelle salle pour laquelle il a fallu
se battre
le président ne compte pas ses heures il
faut savoir quand même que bon c'est pas
que moi ça prend quand même du temps
l'année dernière j'ai partie du jour en
vacances faut que j'ai une épouse qui
soit quand même conciliante pour
accepter ce que je vais faire un an
durée pourra par rapport au basket
le basket doit donc beaucoup à pierre
fosset au delà des titres gagnés c'est
aussi lui qui a organisé les premiers
états généraux du sport féminin en 2013
a bourges un président dont l'objectif
est que les femmes soient mieux
considérés dans le sport